Priyanka Chopra fangirls over her man
Nick Jonas
Demi Lovato enters rehab plus the
biggest revelations from Beyonce's vogue
sa hello it's Monday it sucks I know but
we're thriving anyway plus Beyonce's on
the cover of Vogue and is speaking to my
soul more on that in just a few but
first we talk about Priyanka Chopra
being all cute and cheering on her man
Nick Jonas at his concert in Singapore
fans were freaking out when they spotted
Priyanka in the crowd and eye witness
tells et you can hear them screaming
congratulations to the rumoured soon to
be mrs. Jonas all night but Priyanka was
hyped for her boo snapping pics and
dancing to a set a concert goer tells et
Priyanka was hyping Nick up from her
seat quote she was glowing and smiling
throughout the whole thing so I could
really see she was in love Nick
reportedly popped the question in London
on Priyanka 36 birthday and now he has a
fangirl for life and we stand a
supportive fiance meanwhile Blake
Shelton has yet to put a ring on Gwen
Stefani as far as we know but the couple
who sings together stays together
Gwen surprised fans during Blake
Shelton's performance at watershed music
and camping festival and Iliff bananas
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
country clouds go ham guys you are
switching gears now though to the latest
on Demi Lovato two weeks after her drug
overdose we've learned Demi is now in
rehab a source tells et Demi's family
and team decided that the best situation
for Demi sobriety was for her to check
into an inpatient facility is her second
time in rehab the first time she went
she was just 18 years old on Sunday the
singer broke her silence about her OD
writing I want to thank God for keeping
me alive and well and telling fans the
love you have all shown me will never be
forgotten and I look forward to the day
where I can say I came out on the other
side ask for her decision to go to rehab
a source tells ety quote it took a long
hospital stay and time to detox for Demi
to get some clarity
everyone is breathing a huge sigh of
relief and I gotta say Demi I am rooting
for you girl we need that voice and that
talent of yours around for years to come
right now moving on to the music icon of
them all Beyonce now you know I worship
the ground she walks on I'm even rocking
my beat Talisman mm-hmm and I'm not sure
we deserve her and here's why B is
changing up the game by inviting others
into it music Titan looks flawless on
the cover of Vogue skub at its September
issue and hand-picked 23 year-old Tyler
Mitchell to take her photos the first
black photographer to shoot a Vogue
cover in 126 years people Beyonce penned
a personal essay for the mag and says
it's important to her that she helps
open doors for younger artists now mama
fierce also unleashes her body
positivity specifically about her Fupa
that's right the 36 year old mom of
three who stripped away the wigs and
hair extensions and used very little
makeup in the issue says she is a no
rush to get rid of her little mommy
pouch and is embracing her fuller figure
sure she'll go into beast mode to get
that six-pack back one day but B says
and that quote right now my little Foofa
and I feel like we are meant to be and
with that summer body's cancelled poopa
season forever making hard to believe
that beyonce reveals she was 218 pounds
where she gave birth to twins roomie and
sir she says that was caused by swelling
due to toxemia which
a sudden rise in blood pressure and
being on bed rest for over a month she
had an emergency c-section and then went
into survival mode because six months
later she started prepping for Coachella
she reportedly lost 30 pounds in three
weeks and says by going vegan
temporarily giving up coffee alcohol and
fruit drinks but Beyonce says with pride
that she enjoyed her fuller curves after
the babies were born she also feels more
powerful than ever and expresses hope
that her two daughters will see
themselves represented in positions of
power and she wants her son to be strong
but also carrying of emotion so how's
that for some Monday motivation agreed
more on Beyonce's vulgar revelations on
ET online.com that's it for me thanks
for watching and I'll be back tomorrow
[Music]